pj tucker
[Music]
[Applause]
yo pj needs a minute
[Applause]
pj you said this group was full of some
dogs
you said they were full of some dogs how
did they display that
on this championship run you know it's
crazy
that's where everybody like i came here
they're like yo
you got to like show like you got to be
the dog and i'm like
man we got dogs like they just saying
like
like i got here like we we already got
dogs
they just don't know how to be dogs and
we gonna be dogs
and our dogs is crazy we got
dogs jimmy milwaukee we dogs
you you were you were emotional as that
buzzer sounded on tuesday
and you talked about all the trials and
tribulations that have led you to this
point
how sweet is the end my friend
[Applause]
you can't make this up man these dudes
this organization what we what we put
together
you can't make this up this ain't we
don't it don't no no
nothing matter except what's going on
right here
right now that's all it matters
they say what they want
but they gotta say we chants
[Music]
one more swing for the crowd one more
swig for the crowd
one
bj tucker everybody